all right important question
rice or bread
in terms of what in terms of in terms of
like General consumption in terms of you
have to pick one the other one
disappears from the world and you can
only have you can only have rice or
bread for the rest of your life with any
meal
oh which which carbs you pick which
carbs you pick right
I'm I'm you know I'm and that's not
because I'm white
I think there's there's substitutes for
for rice that exist okay so I don't
always need rice I'll be sad I'll be sad
that fried rice is gone no no I'll be
sad no you don't always need bread but I
could always do I could always do with
some rice man are you telling me that
means that means some of the most goaded
Foods on Earth are gone like sandwiches
and burgers and hot dogs I think we have
onigiri for a reason right you know
that's that's yeah Japanese
because they have the sandwiches right
next to the onigiri which one do you go
for right okay I'm a sandwich guy I'm I
you know the I do but I do I do
sometimes get on again yeah my God this
is the one time I regret being half
asian
I can't decide
or give up rice with like half of the
meals I cook first of all company
sandwiches and and on a curious let's
talk about that for a second okay I
agree sandwiches better than onigiri but
onigiri is like a gamble I feel like the
filling quality you get is so 50 50 and
if you get no filling in it I feel so
bad that I just ate a block of rice I'm
like [__] that didn't taste good and
with like sandwiches always always good
you always get the same level yeah I
mean like you'd be giving up some like
goaded things like you know Pizza that
would be pizza's gone are you telling me
that you're willing to get rid of pizza
I don't even think about that you know
you know what I would you know because
like to me so to me rice is the perfect
just neutral thing you know it's just
give me any meat any kind of meal and
like you need some kind of neutral
filling with that rice is just rice just
plays that role perfectly it's wheat
gone is this is this like this is
everything that we've spaced gone is
beer gone no no no no just just
specifically break you know if you're
good I've come to my decision okay I
thought about long and hard I love both
bread and rice okay but I'm gonna have
to say with bread on this one oh I'm
gonna I'm gonna have to say with German
side one day my German side has won yeah
just because I'm thinking about the
sheer variety of breads as opposed to
the sheer variety of rice and rice as
much as I love it a lot of times can be
replaced with bread in a lot of meals
a lot of Asian things but yeah in in the
case with like a carb companion yeah a
lot of things can be replaced with bread
like how are you gonna eat soup without
bread now let's go with rice
yeah yeah actually I mean you can but I
know you can actually we do that in
Thailand actually you know
it depends on this you can't you can eat
you can you can I'm telling you I'm
telling you I mean you can't you can
stick your dick in the fridge doesn't
mean you should
I can but I'm not going to there is
nothing wrong actually you know
depending on the soup some soup goes so
well with rice you know okay look I get
it okay actually yeah yeah totally like
I cannot imagine eating uh Tom Yum and
like soup curry I understand right like
rice is probably the better companion
but in the in the wider world of soups
bread is the goat I'm not saying rice is
better than bread I'm just saying you
know it's right rice in in in a starving
world in in in a starving World okay in
in a world where aliens have invaded
Earth and you know gummed your head rice
or bread which one goes I would be like
I'm keeping the bread I would be like oh
I think I would keep the rice isn't like
uh katsu's gone too because that's
breading right and like fried chicken
that's bread technically there's a bit
of breading huh that's true I mean
that's that's true I mean that's like
flour now that I'm thinking about it I
think that Curry like Japanese Curry
would go bomb with bread I think it's oh
yeah I feel like we can we cocoa cars
just get rid of the rice let's just
bread a side of bread and just scoop it
up but that sounds so good I mean they
do the cauliflower rice which actually
goes quite exactly yo exactly we don't
need rice
we have cauliflower cauliflower rice is
so good you know actually in America did
you remember when I ordered that thing I
ordered cauliflower chicken yeah yeah I
didn't know what it was yeah and it
looked like exactly like a piece of
fried chicken on the outside yeah
remember this with the buffalo sauce no
I don't
um no no it's like a it's like a dry rub
it was weird oh and you bite into this
piece that looks exactly like a thick
piece of fried chicken and it was just a
piece of cauliflower yeah it's crazy I'm
sorry it's blew my mind cauliflower is
coated yeah so good like we we have a
bad image of cauliflower because it
seems to be that one thing we always
hated as a kid but no I loved it as a
kid he loved it as a kid yeah in the UK
you always had like cauliflower like a
creamy cheese sauce thing it was always
really good oh that sounds good my
parents wouldn't serve it to me that I
think they thought it was too bad for me
but my friend's house did
yeah I never got that I just got like
the normal boiled cauliflower so yeah me
too yeah I like that too you like that
as well I like actually you just you
just love every vegetable I love veg man
they're just so good characters man but
every other veg is pretty good all right
all right noodles or pasta
what am I keeping yeah what are you
keeping
like a million times isn't that way oh
no there's a lot of noodles there isn't
all of noodles there's a lot of noodles
I feel like we've had this date I'm
gonna Deja Vu we had this discussion I
feel like I was about to say there's way
more I might have I was about to say
there's way more noodles of pasta uh way
more variation pasta then I think you
rebuttaled no there was way more
variations I think it might have been
one of our like First episodes where we
talked about like food I don't think
we've what if we're literally reliving
in Thai and this is like so weird so I
was gonna clip inside I think we might
have had a similar conversation off
camera I don't think we've had it I you
know I I think I feel like this would I
feel like if it is it would be a bigger
meme probably I feel like I would have
seen some memes on the subway for sure
pasta yeah I'm a pasta
yeah I'm sorry guys I love my noodles
man I just it would feel it would feel
so bad losing out on all of the noodles
all of the ramen
Chinese
but honestly Italians I gotta [__]
give it to you guys you you guys you
guys made something goaded yeah yeah I
could not I could not get it's my
favorite carb it is it is hands down
hands down pasta pasta goated car yeah
never met a single person who doesn't
like pasta yeah I know everybody loves
it
it's like Italian cuisine right what
what's what's the most widely seen
Cuisine you've seen around the world
because I think to me it's maybe Italian
yes it's the easiest one to get no
matter where I go in the world you know
sometimes you find a hard time finding
like you know Mexican restaurants then
you're in America no problem you know
sometimes you have to have a hard time
maybe finding French food or you know
Thai food you know
um but like I've never had a hard time
finding an Italian restaurant yeah and
like even you know a lot of people I
think are going to say like Chinese food
but I feel like
that's Chinese food and then there's
Chinese yeah I don't okay here's the
thing I don't think Chinese food exists
right in the sense okay let's get out of
content yeah yeah I don't think it's
real in in the sense where I don't think
Chinese food can be branded as in one
under one umbrella right right do you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
because because Chinese food isn't real
no because like different parts of China
have different like styles of Cuisines
yeah you're trying to say yeah yeah it's
like the variationally though as well
yeah like the variation in Chinese food
is so [__] like large that if I if I
go to a place and it's just like oh this
is a Chinese food restaurant I'm just
like that's that's us what part what
does that mean what does that mean is it
is it you know cantonin Cantonese
cuisine is it you know
um you know there's China has like so
many different styles of Cuisine that I
would like to know which which part of
China which cuisine am I eating rather
than if it's just Chinese food I I think
this comes from growing up in the UK
um when it's Chinese food in the UK it's
it's it's awful a lot of Chinese food in
the UK is awful because it's just your
Baseline here is westernized Chinese
food as opposed to actual Chinese
cuisine
um and so finding
funding like actual specialized Chinese
cuisine
um is a lot harder than finding good
Italian food in my opinion yeah I want
to say that next time I go to a Panda
Express I'm like oh what part of China
is this from yeah yeah
in America is like Belly Chinese food
yeah yeah I had uh I remember having
this argument with uh with a May in
England and I was like yeah I sweet and
sour chicken that's not real Chinese
food you know you go to China and you
try and find sweet and sour chicken
you're not going to be able to find that
you know and he's like no no no no no
it's it's everywhere it's everywhere I
swear to God it's my favorite Chinese
food you know and I'm saying you know
that's kind of like saying orange
chicken yeah like what do you mean I
can't get orange chicken in China
Chinese food yeah yeah
um but yeah to me Italian Italians are
goated with their food and it's also I
think one of the easiest Cuisine to find
Worldwide I've not been to a country so
far where I've had a hard time finding
Italian in a good Italian restaurant
kind of like anywhere that's true yeah
you got it Italians congratulations
congratulations on the pasta you got
that dog yeah what do you guys think
about French food
uh not as good as Italian I mean it's
all it's all right okay this okay here's
the thing French have the image of being
like you know oh we we have like the
best food you know this is where all of
the culinary like Giants are you gonna
just stop that we have the best blank
French fruits I've used to go to friends
every year for like you know [__]
forever yeah for like three weeks at a
time and like french food in in France
was amazing uh and it was so good in the
world yeah yeah and then when you leave
France to get actually good french who
you have to pay out the ass oh yeah yeah
whereas I feel like Italian kind of
travels a little better you can get
dishes I feel like you need to pay out
the ass while you're in Paris as well
yeah oh yeah I mean outside of Paris is
great yeah you know it's a lot more
affordable to get really good quality
stuff Insurance
um but yeah just it doesn't export well
I think that's the problem is that
Italian kind of like food it's very easy
to kind of make it in more palatable to
whatever culture or whatever country
you're in for an affordable price it's
more customizable yeah yeah yeah and um
I just think yeah Francis is the problem
where to get really good french food
abroad you have to spend
so that's why it feels like kind of like
more bougie Italian and sometimes you're
like yeah [__] it no I've got Italian
well it's it's like French always has I
think everything French has this image
that is bougie yeah French French
language sounds bougie a lot of the
times
um but yeah like I think one thing I
noticed because
you know you know I've said before that
I spent a lot of money a lot a lot of my
disposable income
um trying out different restaurants
because that's like I guess my favorite
thing to spend money on nowadays
um like going one thing that always
bothers me about going to let's say
fancy restaurants right you know you
know higher tier end restaurants
um is that
everyone's kind of agreed right it's you
know they taste really good is it worth
the price a lot of times no it's not
worth the price a lot of times you go
for the experience you go for this kind
of like rare ingredient that you can't
get anywhere else it's kind of like
you're paying for like the Rarity as
opposed to the how good it tastes a lot
of times
um but one thing that always bothers me
is a lot of like high-class restaurants
I go to they it tastes
doesn't taste the same but they never go
too far of this like taste profile
nothing ever tastes too strong you know
there's there's always like a subtle
hint of something and sometimes I just
want to maybe this is the Southeast
Asian of me talking some I want to see
what happens if some if if there is a
fine dining or a high-class restaurant
that just that just commits to having a
really spicy food of really really
strong taste because obviously that's
not going to appeal to anyone or
everyone
um but I that's that's one thing I would
like to see I feel though those exist
especially in Japan in like the mom and
pop shops right where it's like they're
not afraid to not you know uh pertain to
the what do you mean by mum and pop
shops you know like the locally owned
places yeah that have been around for
like several Generations you know that
maybe specialize in a particular dish or
a particular style of dish yeah because
they're not afraid of alienating the
general yeah consensus like exactly they
just they just want to they're like we
have this one thing yeah and this is our
gimmick and if you [__] with it then you
can come back at any time no but if you
don't then go somewhere else you know
like they don't care about becoming like
this you know big thing or having this
you know large name in the in the
restaurant world if you will so it's
like you know because like some of the
weirdest [__] I've ever eaten and I've
eaten a lot of weird [__] in my life has
always been in the most like dingy local
places that just don't really give a
[__] they're like yeah this is our weird
thing yo you like it cool thanks I'm
curious about you Joey how when when
have you had like a shokugeki moment you
know the [__] you you take a take I
mean the Korean fried chicken I almost
oh really okay okay and also that's the
first time I went to that skimming place
I took you guys yeah that was Superman
like there are a few dishes that have
made me had the show King moments to
come in is like one of those places
there's a lot of Thai Dishes I remember
as a child that still you know sticks
with me until it's day
um first time lasagna man of course my
first list I still remember with that
[__] man it wasn't even like a great
lasagna but I'm just like holy [__] sure
holy [__] how can how could you improve
pastor of both yeah that's good yeah
that's good what about you Connor Sonya
just most Foods he has one every day
yeah that's true that's true I think as
long as it's not pasta and salt I'm a
I'm a Nut
anything's a nut he's experienced the
bottom of the barrel so anything else
I'm very easy to please with food
um I just want something that makes me
fall and taste good and I'm happy I feel
that's why it was such [__] chefs yeah
yeah because if we actually cared about
food that's why I don't want to I don't
wanna I don't want to get a better
palate I I [__] love what I eat right
now yeah that's true I think I think I
think like I I don't know I think uh
going on a tangent I've tried like
cooking a bit more and obviously I'm
biased but uh I think I could be a
pretty good cook and I think part of the
reason I could be a pretty good cook is
because I'm a really picky eater oh yeah
I want things to taste exactly I have a
have a way that I want them to taste
exactly in my mind and when I get that
I'm like holy [__] this stays fine well
I would argue that's what makes the best
chefs right like they actually care
about what goes into the food and the
small subtleties of what makes a dish
great like if you didn't give a [__]
about it then you'd be like you end up
like Mr pastor and salt over here yeah
where it's just like if it's edible it's
going in my tummy if I had more time I'd
probably cook more because I do enjoy
cooking I do enjoy the final result
there's a lot there's a lot of things I
enjoy in life I enjoy the final result I
don't enjoy the aftermath or some of the
process of what happens before that
final result but when you get that final
result in it's it's really it's it's so
[__] satisfying yeah I sound like
mail-in right now she's rubbing off on
you maybe even hang out with me in too
much yeah